Transcriber: Nehal elsotuhy
المدقّق: Fatima Alwalidi
مساء الخير..
كيف كانت بداية يومكم اليوم؟
أتوقع أنكم استيقظتم من النوم..
دخلتم دورة المياه..
ثم نظفتم أسنانكم
من المفترض أنكم فعلتم
قمتم بالاستحمام
ثم خرجتم
وأفطرتم إفطارًا شهيًا
مع أهلكم، أو مع أصدقائكم،
أو حتى مع أنفسكم
قمتم بشرب كوب ماء بارد
ومن الممكن كوب من الشاي، أو القهوة
حسب ما تفضلونه
أتوقع بعد ذلك قمتم باختيار
ملابسكم المفضلة
ثم خرجتم، وجئتم هنا اليوم
وأتوقع أن هذه بداية الأيام
الاعتيادية بالنسبة للكل
فحسب إحصائيات الأمم المتحدة..
ثمانمئة واثنين وتسعون
مليون شخصًا في العالم
لا يمتلكون مراحيضًا في بيوتهم لقضاء حاجتهم
حتى أنهم يضطرون لقضاء حاجتهم في العراء
اثنين فاصل اثنين مليار شخص حول العالم
يفتقرون لمياه شرب تتم إدارتها بأمان.
بإمكانكم تخيل الكم الهائل من الناس
حول العالم
التي تفتقر الأشياء البسيطة
التي نمتلكها كل يوم.
دعونا نسميها النعم المنسية
مثل كونك تخرج من البيت وترى أمامك
مجموعة الأحذية التي تملكها
وتختار أيها تناسبك أكثر هذا اليوم.
وفي المقابل هناك أناس لا يملكون
شيئًا لارتدائه في أرجلهم.
والكهرباء التي لا نستغني عنها يوميًا
والحواس الخمس التي يستحيل
أن نتخيل العيش بدونها
فدائمًا ما نسمع عبارات مثل..
“احمد ربك، فما عندك قد لا يمتلكه غيرك”
ونشعر بالملل من مثل هذه العبارات
وأنها لم تعد تؤثر بنا
ولكن هل تساءلنا من قبل_بشكل جدي_
لماذا من المهم أن نفكر بهذه الطريفة؟
لماذا يعد من المهم أن نستشعر بحق
كل ما حولنا، وكل ما نملكه
الناس، الأماكن، الأحداث..
الحوارات العابرة البسيطة
المناظر الحلوة الكثيرة
التي نتمتع بها في عمان
والصحة .
نسمع دائمًا عن مصطلح الامتنان
وكيف يساعدنا لعيش حياةٍ أفضل.
تعريف الامتنان حسب كلية
الطب في جامعة هارفرد..
هو تقدير شيء ملموس أو غير ملموس
يدفع الناس لإدراك النعم من حولهم
ويؤدي لتواصلهم مع ما هو أكبر من أنفسهم.
ولكن السؤال لماذا يعد الامتنان
مهمًا في حياتنا بشكل عام؟
لأنه ببساطة أتوقع أن جميعنا
يركض وراء السعادة
نحتاج السعادة في حياتنا،
نحتاج أن  نصل للسعادة
من الممكن أن نكتب جميعًا اليوم قائمة طويلة
تحتوي على الأشياء التي
تحقق لنا السعادة في حياتنا
ومن ضمن هذه الأشياء سنجد بالتأكيد
المال، المنصب..
العلاقات، الأصدقاء، والأهل..
الإنجاز العلمي والعملي.
وبالتالي كلما تعلمت أن تركز على امتنانك
ومدى امتنانك لنفسك، لأهلك، لأصدقائك..
تصير حياتك أسهل وأجمل.. ولو بقدر أبسط.
ومن الطبيعي وجود تحديات كبيرة في حياتنا
ولكنك تواجه هذه التحديات بشكل أفضل..
لأنك دائمًا ما تشعر بوجود شيء تمتن له
وتعلم أنه مهما ازدادت الأمور صعوبة..
دائمًا ما تكون النتائج تستحق
كل ما مررت به من تعب.
الامتنان يجعلك قادرًا على رؤية الجانب
الجيد والإيجابي من حياتك بشكل عام
في كل مراحل حياتك.
وبالتالي تشعر بقدر أكبر
من السعادة والرضا.
الدكتور محمد الحاجي دكتور متخصص
في العلوم السلوكية والاجتماعية..
عرف السعادة على أنها
هرم ماسلو مغلف بالامتنان
أي بكل بساطة إذا كنت تمتلك
احتياجاتك الأساسية
وتمتلك الأمان.
وتمتلك علاقات صحية، وجيدة، وقوية،
وتمتلك القدر الكافي
من التقدير والاحترام من الغير..
وأنت راضٍ عن نفسك.
ولم تشعر بأي امتنان حقيقي
تجاه كل ما امتلكته وحققته من أشياء..
فكلها لن تحقق لك مصدرًا
للسعادة الحقيقة بالنسبة لك..
بل وتكون كلها عبارة عن سعادة مؤقتة.
كيف يمكنني أن أتعلم أو أتدرب على الامتنان؟
وكيف يمكنني أن أجعل الامتنان يصل لمرحلة
أن يكون أسلوب حياة بالنسبة لي.
هذا بالنسبة لي شخصيًا يعد منهجًا مفتوحًا
لا تحده أي قواعد، أو قوانين،
أو كتابات معينة صحيحة.
يمكنكم البحث عن الطرق الأفضل والأسهل لكم..
فهذا يعتمد على شخصياتكم.
ولكن من من باب مشاركة التجربة..
عن نفسي أحب دائمًا بشكل يومي..
وأحاول أن أستمر على هذه العادة
عندما أستلقي على فراشي ليلًا لكي أنام
أغمض عيوني..
وأحاول أن أتذكر على الأقل ثلاثة أشياء
جميلة حدثت لي على مدار يومي.
فمثلًا احتسيت اليوم صباحًا
كوب قهوةٍ لذيذٍ جدًا..
تحاورت مع أحد أصدقائي..
تواصلت مع أهلي، وجئت إلى هنا اليوم.
هناك عدة طرق تجعلك..
تحول هذه من مجرد مشاعر
إلى أشياء شبه ملموسة..
عن طريق كتابتها وتدوينها في دفتر عندك
أو أنك تشاركها في وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
في حالة إنستغرام، أو منشور، أو تكتبها
في تغريدة على تويتر.
فقط لكي تحولها من مجرد شعور عابر
إلى شيء شبه ملموس وحقيقي..
لكي تشعر بها حقًا.
في دراسات كثيرة أجرتها مراكز بحوث وعلوم..
وجدوا بعد إجراء أشعة الرنين المغناطيسي
لأشخاص..
أعطوا شعورًا بالامتنان أو شعروا به.
إلى أن أكثر منطقة تحفزًا في الدماغ
تسمى قشرة الفص الوسطي
وهي المنطقة المسؤولة عن
التحكم بالمشاعر السلبية والسيئة..
وتنشيط الناقلات العصبية التي تساعد عقلنا..
على إعادة هيكلة الأفكار
والمشاعر الضارة والسلبية..
والتحسين من إدارتنا
لحالاتنا الشعورية بشكل عام.
وبالتالي عندما تقوم بممارسة
الامتنان بشكل مستمر..
يغير ذلك من إدراكك المعرفي
للمشاعر السلبية..
والأضرار التي تسببها لك..
وبشكل عام يقلل من توترك ويجعلك تشعر
باستقرار نفسي أفضل.
وهناك مقولة تنص على أن
الامتنان يقربك للرضا.
أتوقع وأنا أتكلم الآن عن الامتنان..
أن كلنا في هذه القاعة..
نرى أمام أعيننا الآن صورة شخص..
نمتن له بشكل كبير في حياتنا..
أو موقف، أو حدث، أو كتاب،
أو فيلم، أو منبر..
وأنا متأكد...متأكد..
أن كلكم الآن..
تشعرون بالامتنان لنعمة البصر..
ممتنون على النعم البسيطة في حياتنا..
التي اعتدنا على وجودها بشكل دائم..
نعتبرها شيئًا يحدث ويدوم للأبد..
الله تعالى يقول “ولئن شكرتم لأزيدنكم”
صدق الله العظيم.
وهذا دليل إضافي على أن الشعور بالامتنان..
له تأثير كبير علينا
نفسيًا، جسديًا، واجتماعيًا..
وهو شيء أساسي جدًا لديمومة النعم.
وفي رحلتنا لتحقيق المزيد في حياتنا..
سواء أموال، منصب، إنجاز..
يجب أن نكون حقًا ممتنين لما نمتلكه.
أنا محمد الغريبي..
وفي هذه اللحظة..
أنا ممتن لكم جميعًا..
شكرًا جزيلًا.
(تصفيق)